désormais votre pass navigo vous permet
d'accéder à des lieux culturels dans les
yvelines 21 exactement aujourd'hui on se
trouve au château de breteuil gimont
pass navigo on va voir quel avantage de
ne pas avoir
[Applaudissements]
alors pour ma part c'est la première
fois que je viens au château de breteuil
à choisel c'est la première fois que je
découvre du coup jean emmanuel ou est ce
qu on est déjà pour commencer dans
quelle pièce on se situe alors nous
sommes ici dans la grande galerie c'est
dire la gauche du château le château a
été construit il ya 400 ans et il s'est
toujours transmis depuis quatre siècles
au sein de la même famille il y a donc
génération après génération ou une
accumulation de beaucoup de souvenirs de
famille que vous pouvez découvrir au fil
de la visite est ici dans cette galerie
de portraits il ya notamment les
ministres qu'il ya eu dans la famille
breteuil qui ont servi les rois de
france et il y à de magnifiques
portraits royaux également de louis saez
de louis xviii du grand dauphin et vous
verrez d'autres portraits royaux
également dans les autres pièces du
château quels sont les autres pièces
qu'on peut visiter alors il ya des
salons avec de magnifiques tapisseries
et puis au premier étage tout un circuit
historique avec des personnages de cire
du musée grévin qui font qui raconte
l'histoire de la famille à travers
l'histoire de france et il ya comme ça
grâce à grévin plusieurs breteuil qui
reçoivent louis sage louis xviii marcel
proust voltaire une succession de
petites scènes historiques ce qui rend
la visite très vivante et très ludique
et les jeunes enfants apprécient
énormément parce que c'est beaucoup
moins lassant évidemment qu'une
succession de meubles et puis même pour
les adultes c'est très parlant de voir
louis xviii par exemple dans son
fauteuil roulant c'est un vrai intérêt
plutôt que de voir le fauteuil vide et
donc là on est au rez de chaussée
ensuite on va aller tâche pour commencer
sa plongée à lundi c'est parti
[Musique]
et donc aujourd'hui moi je visite le
château de breteuil grâce à mon taf
navigo
comment est-ce que c'est venu vous en
avez discuté avec la région et bien
la région nous a proposé de mettre en
place un système de partenariat qui
offre aux visiteurs ayant le pass navigo
une réduction dans différents lieux
culturels ou monuments breteuil a
accepté de faire partie de ce
partenariat est donc en venant avec
votre pass navigo visiter breteuil vous
bénéficiez automatiquement du tarif
réduit c'est à dire environ 2 euros de
moins sur tous les billets enfant ou
adulte et donc là on arrive au cabinet
des trésors oui c'est ce qu'on appelle
le cabinet trésor parce que il y à fait
magnifique table au centre de la pièce
dans cette table c'est le trésor
familial
alors elle a été vendue au louvre il y a
cinq ans mais nous allons préfère cette
magnifique réplique pour continuer à
raconter l'histoire de ce bijou et
surtout le rôle médiatique du baron de
breteuil sous louis saez qui par sa
diplomatie a mis fin à la guerre de
succession de bavière une guerre qui
allait embraser toute l'europe centrale
et cette table et bien c'est le cadeau
qu'ils avaient reçu pour voir rétabli la
paix eh bien merci beaucoup jean
emmanuel pour cette visite très
instructive du château de vaux sur en
vie nous avons avec le lie à bretelles